[Music]
[Music]
says dear BJ my best friend currently
told me she cheated on her boyfriend I
wound up with an STD she doesn't want to
tell him because she doesn't want to get
caught
should I tell her boyfriend what's going
on because his health is at risk I like
to stay out of people business but if
you rock with her boyfriend she probably
you know she's probably not gonna be
happy with you saying that but they
probably they're not a sex the way I
feel she don't want to tell them Shane
told him they'd probably act like
nothing ever happened if nothing ever
happens then you go out Friday night
which I love women y'all have dinner and
what happens after dinner with persons
with is sometimes sex so yeah I got a
situation on y'all and I say I'll try my
best but that's wicked somebody got to
save some money that's why I do
deer BJ I'm in the friend zone and can't
seem to get out what do I do you find
somebody that doesn't perceive you as
being in the friend zone you never want
to be where you don't need to be you
don't want to be where somebody don't
want you to be especially relationships
you would never get what you're looking
for you would never get what you expect
you only give that's like I try my best
with this this is my logo for this dear
BJ my boyfriend picked fights for two
weeks leading up to Valentine's Day and
then broke up with me on the 12th
Valentine's Day has passed and now he
wants to get back together should I take
him back absolutely not he probably with
another chick on Valentine's Day gonna
fall for it go for it but I mean I don't
break up with you on the 24th of
December and didn't come back on 26 dear
BJ my girlfriend lives with her baby
father but says that there aren't
messing around any longer should I
believe her should I tell her that she
needs to move out I think you should
mind your business because they have a
child and let them do what's best for
them so does that I love throwing the
paper it's like very gangster in there
BJ I recently found out that me and two
of my best friends are seeing the same
guy who should have to cut him off
if both of whom if both of you guys like
them that much flip a coin gonna make
them take both of you guys out okay this
this this this person is asking if
someone across the country is worth
pursuing
I think long-distance relationships are
for people that are willing to have
long-distance heartbreak or gamble in
the long way and like new online I think
it's a big gamble you don't know you
can't be with the person as much you can
in the same city so your brain may be
wondering sometimes they don't answer
the phone or they you know I'll be up
you know but um me personally I'm not
really into long-distance relationships
I need you here it's bad enough my life
is the way there is I'd be going a lot
both of us going a lot oh man you don't
go through it
my situation is a little bit different
me personally if you're capable to fly
over there or she fry here whatever the
case may be
proceed I mean I'm always with the movie
moves yeah I'm saying if you you feel
like you have a moving moment and you
want to fly over there and see if it's
like love at first sight try it but make
sure you have a lot of other things to
doing you in that city because it might
not be what you take it makes you have a
good time for your trip please
you
[Music]